I know there we were talking about the
quarantine measures set to be introduced
at UK airports and ports now these will
see arrivals to the UK asked to isolate
for 14 days with government
accommodation provided for people
without a home to talk to appropriate
time then to talk with the chief
executive of the UK's biggest airport
Heathrow
John Holland came so Harlan came very
good morning to you let us start them
out straightaway with the with the
isolation the self quarantine the
quarantine strategy as announced by the
government it doesn't help an industry
that relies on people got leaving the
United Kingdom going on holiday or
indeed coming to the United Kingdom to
spend their time on holiday it doesn't
but the first priority is to make sure
that we tackle this terrible virus and
if this is what is required by the
government at this stage then so be it
what we need to do though is start
planning ahead for how we start to
reopen our borders as many other
countries are doing so that we can start
to get the economy back on its feet once
the virus has been tackled and with
aviation this is not just about going on
holiday aviation is the lifeblood of the
UK economy so many manufacturers rely on
the supply chain coming in by air their
exports go by air and a little-known
fact is that 40 percent of all of the
UK's exports go on passenger planes from
Heathrow and that is how fundamental it
is to the UK economy so we need to think
hand-in-hand as Caroline was saying with
reopening aviation as we start to build
back the UK economy and will give us an
idea then of the of the drop in traffic
that you've experienced to Heathrow so
passenger numbers have fallen by 97% so
we have gone from serving around a
quarter of a million passengers every
day to around 5 or 6,000 passengers and
these are mainly passengers who are
repatriating either coming home to the
UK all going home to other countries and
quite often of course they are
quarantined when they get to their
destination so this is a very minimal
level of traffic and I think that as
long as the quarantine is in place that
will continue at those low levels but
the quarantine cannot be in place for
more than a relatively short amount of
time if we are
to get the economy moving again so there
needs to be a plan for what comes next
and this is where I've been converging
the government to have a common
international standard working with
other countries so that traffic can
start to flow in a more normal way
between low-risk countries just just on
that on that particular topic John I
mean what what is the International and
forum in which this plan these standards
could be drawn up I mean we have seen
goodness only knows how many different
public health strategies in terms of
dealing with corvid 19 almost as many as
there are countries around the world and
one rather fears that that might be the
same when it get comes to the reopening
of the aviation industry well you're
exactly right and as we went into this
crisis every country had its own plan
and that I think is led to a lot of
confusion among passengers as to what
they should expect when they're
traveling and as we come out of the
crisis we need to have something which
is more consistent so we can not just
build confidence but also make it safe
for people to travel again and there are
government bodies such as ICAO the the
UN agency that can lead this but
actually I think that if the UK
government with one of the biggest
aviation sectors in the world were to
get together with the European Union and
the United States between them they have
the heft and the global diplomatic and
economic power to set that international
standard and I think that the approach
to take is a risk-based approach as we
do with security
where if two countries are a very low
risk of having the transmission within
each country there should be a free flow
of passengers between those countries
but of course if a country has very high
risk with rising infection rates and
poor controls then there be very tight
controls on anyone accessing the UK from
those markets I think that's the kind of
thing we should be thinking about for
the next phase in a month or so as time
as we start to see the infection rates
coming down in this country and we want
to start opening up the economy again
what if any what if any role do you see
for the the antibody test that we're
hearing much more about these days a
test that would be able to indicate
whether or not someone had previously
had covered 19 are you of a mind that we
could see something that I've seen
described as an immunity passport
brought in I think those are the kind of
things which
to be looking at but again we need to
have some consistency between countries
as to how this works
there's no good having the UK having a
health passport if another country has
the entirely different system well you
really need to do is to have that
commonality between markets so that you
know that if you've got your health
passport that is going to be accepted in
the country you are going to and you'll
be allowed to return home safely without
having any kind of quarantine or risk of
of being locked up at any part of your
journey so I think antibody testing the
testing for whether you have the the
illness they have a role to play and but
we probably need to get to a point where
the science is a little bit more certain
and the tests are a little bit quicker
before those can really be effective but
this is where we need to work with the
government and with other governments to
make sure that there is this common
international standard but I think I
think testing in a number of ways could
be very powerful one thing we are doing
at Ypres is testing thermal imaging
which we know has its limitations it is
very widely used in many other countries
as being the main screen for whether
people have Kove it or not and we're
working with public health England to
see if that could be part of the
solution to health screening at airports
but it's much better that the health
screen takes place at the start of your
journey before you board a plane ban at
your destination because that way you
know that there is no risk once you get
to your destination you might find
yourself being interred by being
interned by the border force equivalent
in the country you're going to what
effective any is all of this had on the
third runway well I think we're clearly
going through a deep economic recession
but the market will come back and the UK
is a global trading nation and we will
desperately need that third runway
within the next 10 to 15 years I wish is
about the length of time it takes to
build it so we absolutely need to get on
with building the extra capacity at the
UK's hub airport and we are the UK's
biggest port and the only hub that we
have in the UK and I think what we're
seeing at this time is how airlines are
retrenching to a harbour but we've got
more coming to use Heathrow with the few
flights that they have
and not just under pins how vital
Heathrow is to the UK economy and as we
come out of this we need to plan to be
able to connect all of the UK markets to
global markets around the world more
flights to China and India that we
currently can't serve but also
guaranteed flights to UK regions like
Scotland Northern Ireland the Southwest
so that businesses there can plan with
confidence knowing that they can access
global markets for themselves and their
goods through Heathrow John Holland Kate
good to see thanks very much for joining
us this morning on the program